Karin is with us in Indianapolis hi
Karin welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
thank you for what you do you're truly
an inspiration Dave well I'm honored how
can I help
I'm trying to prepare for life after
divorce and I'm wondering if I can
afford to stay in the house or if I need
to consider renting an apartment and how
much I can afford for rent
how much is your house payment that you
might stay with 1250 what is your take
home pay my growth is fifty take home as
probably 38 so what I'm not sure okay so
that's about one-third of your take-home
pay would be the house payment right
about 33 percent that's not the end of
the world especially I'm guessing you're
re-entering the job market now I'm
working you're working but I mean yeah
I'm gonna reentered because of this
divorce no I've been working oh okay
what do you do accounting this is the
accounting segment okay so the your
trajectory on your income going up are
you pretty well stable stable okay
here's the thing if your payment is much
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay it
doesn't leave much wiggle room in your
budget to do other things like pay cash
for cars in the future pay cash for
Christmas vacations and invest for your
retirement right and people tend to end
up borrowing for some of those things
and going the wrong direction if they
end up house poor so this is a little
over what I want it to be do you have
children no no is there any reason you
want this house not really no okay good
then I'd probably drop it and get
something a little cheaper and rent a
little while until you emotionally
finish going through this mess
yeah so what would you consider a
thousand would be like the max yeah yeah
okay
for a little while and then let's stop
and look and go okay because the point
is you can afford more than that and you
can qualify for a mortgage for a lot
more than that okay but the point is you
end up giving all your money to the
house and you know what I mean when I
say house poor yeah and I don't want
that yeah you do accounting and so
there's just no disposable income
there's no wiggle room no margin in your
budget and by being in the ends up that
the math ends up putting you against the
wall with a gun and hand holding you
hostage and you and you get you know car
breaks down then you got a problem and
you can't do anything everything's tight
because of the stupid house so I'm
letting that house go with the divorce
let's sell it and take your equity out
of your portion out of it and yeah
that's what I would do